the other piece of news that we got this
week was the Super Jam now if you
remember a few months ago we had the
organizers on who basically said they
straight out said the artist that's
going to be hosting the Super Jam was
not on the lineup currently and that you
know that came true this week we got the
news from Corey Corey Wong is going to
be the Super Jam I guess uh officiator
and um you know you're not talking to a
a Corey expert here I will be totally
honest with you I've heard the name I've
um I'm certainly familiar enough with
him that he just seems to have his hands
in a lot of different uh places which
means he's you know got a lot of friends
and and can bring a vast amount of sound
to a super GM stage which is exactly
what you want uh I mean you could go
from rockabilly to uh you know some punk
metal with this guy it seems like so it
could be a re yeah I go Bluegrass sure
it could be a really really fun Super
Jam a sneaky Super Jam something that
you're not you weren't really expecting
to be the star of the night but you know
it feels like it's got a little bit of I
don't know for the first time it's got a
little bit of energy mainly because it's
so unknown I don't really know what to
expect we kind of sort of we figured out
what Jack Antonoff is going to bring
with his show last year because they
basically told us this feels a little
mysterious and uh kind of fun
yeah I'm with you I I've heard the name
didn't know a lot uh but when you look
it up I mean it's like oh this makes
perfect sense I mean he's done projects
with uh wolf pack everybody on the
lineup yeah Chris Chris Steely uh Billy
strings I mean do you know uh pretty all
over the place so that's what you want
from a Super Jam or what I want anyway
yeah
with was BD
okay boy go ahead
go ahead Brad
oh my goodness
um it's not me it's not BD Wong it's
Corey Wong no it's not you can only have
one because two Wongs don't make a right
okay
okay he's played with uh Larry Carlton
who I love black
chromium
I guess I'll go now
and see the job here is done insane
exactly
no I I think it's a good pick uh uh was
it what I expected no but I didn't know
what I expect at all that's true but I
think it's a good one
um
so we'll see we'll see what happens
um the problem with the super GM every
year is is
I don't think I've been to a Super Jam
that really even got me maybe in 10
years
and I've been to a Super gym that I've
really really loved which one do I like
Billy Idol uh the one with Billy Idol
and uh Brittany was Brittany was there
singing yeah I'm pretty sure that was
2016. I mean it's been a long time oh
well that's less than 10. but you like a
little bit that was that's like I agree
with you that was a big one well they
didn't
um I like this look I think the Super
Jam is the Super Jam is is the bread and
butter of Bonnaroo and I just kind of
wish that it
always had a little bit more oomph
um but then again you know I can't
really say that with too much Authority
because I always end up skipping it uh I
can't really talk about how much I like
or dislike the Super Jam I'm sure it's
great I just don't always I always end
finding something else to do which you
know what's weird about it we've said
this before the the idea is what was so
appealing for the first 10 years where
you never knew who might show up on
stage with with who yeah and the Super
Jam was like a bigger version
of that and in some ways is it has it
become too um
not predicted predictable yeah it's
unpredictable in this or whatever you
know I mean it's it sort of replaced
this idea of
you know as we've talked about with the
Foo Fighters and who who knows who's
going to show up on stage with them
um kind of ended with the police if I
remember right we all thought that the
police set was going to be such a uh
Super Jam if you will and uh I remember
talking to Stuart Copeland and he was
like yeah this is what we need to do and
sting wouldn't do it he wouldn't change
a note
and so I don't think I knew that story
yeah yeah yeah Stuart Copeland was
coming to Chattanooga and and I was and
he had just done the biggest hang a
second just just to to give a little
background the police did a reunion show
a few reunion shorts shows that you know
one of them happened to be a Bonnaroo
right and for anybody that wasn't there
it was one of the lamest shows that you
might will have ever seen in a Bonnaroo
it had no energy it had no juice these
guys had no they weren't they weren't
even looking at each other on stage it
was one of the moments where you're like
that was a big big swinginess check off
my box but that was it yeah Stuart
coupling Copeland had been there what
the year before the year before with who
I can't remember I'm sorry I'm blanking
but he had been there as part of a uh
the oyster head exactly thank you it
just came to me yeah which was a an
amazing set so the the thought leading
up to the police thing was that you know
it's going to be this police Jam uh this
amazing set and uh
Stewart was here in Chattanooga or maybe
it was part of the Bonnaroo maybe he was
part of one of those
those things where he did a lot of media
and uh he just straight up said told me
because I asked he's like Sting wouldn't
budge a minute he wouldn't budge a note
and so like to your point Brad it was it
was the police it was great you know if
you're a police fan it was note for note
what you wanted to hear but it didn't it
didn't it wasn't what he wanted I don't
I see the reason I I stopped here
because I don't think I've ever heard
that story you're telling me that they
wanted to do Stuart wanted to do a super
jam-ish or bring at least bring other
guests onto the stage yeah uh you know
explore the songs let the songs go where
they wanted to go kind of thing and
thing wasn't having it and I can't
remember his exact quote but it was
something like uh you're not gonna
change things mind or you know he's
precious and he's going to do what he
wants to do kind of thing so is this an
article that you're in for the paper
yeah interesting fascinating huh yeah um
I I did not know that uh but but to that
point
watching back especially the gorillas
set from the second weekend of Coachella
where you know Damon Auburn looks like
he's having the most fun he's ever had
in his career he's got bad bunnies
showing up I'm surprised Rick Hasley
didn't show up on stage at some point
you know it seemed like he had everyone
at the festival coming by and playing
with him I think I'm more into that
these days uh being at it at someone's
set and having them bring out you know
random people instead of being at a big
Super Jam and and knowing somebody's
gonna come out I don't know it's hard to
explain I think I'm I think I'm kind of
um
I think I'm kind of over it
that I think we're saying the same thing
and I didn't know until I just said it
but that was sort of the that police
thing was kind of the end of it for me
um because I haven't done that we have
sat on here before where you know it
feels like the sets are getting shorter
and shorter and they don't do the jams
and they don't do the surprise
uh not like they used to and I don't
know if it's because the industry has
changed or what but I don't disagree
with you that whatever it was 2016 set
with Billy Idol and all that was my
favorite Super Jam the other ones have
been like okay wasn't it more late night
too wasn't that the Super Jam was always
like last year it was always yeah
midnight early
uh you mean yeah yes before it was late
night it was uh Wander over and kind of
basically kind of Wander over and see
who shows up on the back porch type of
thing that was the whole thing and now
it's become a little bit uh
formulaic maybe yeah well also let's be
honest talking out of both sides here a
little bit yeah I know I know but also
to be honest it's hard to do it's really
really hard to do right you know you
can't just like ask random you know
artists who are pretty into their own
methods like oh come on up just play a
few notes that didn't really happen like
that anymore no that's right I mean that
one we're talking about was and it was
such a personal thing for me because
Billy Idol's show was great Britney is a
huge you're a huge fan as we all know
Larry Graham was on that stage Larry
Graham basically invented the slap base
you know so it was it was not only
great music it was getting to see Heroes
and that's hard so yeah I think you're
right it is hard
um and I think that's you know Corey
seems to be
a good pick for that reason because he's
done this this is what he does he's used
to putting these sort of things together
so